good morning rejects this is Greg Alva
here and this is John over here bloom
house has a new film coming out John is
a social media manager for bloom house
so what better person to have in this
video with me than him Jordan Peele
wrote and directed this film it's a
horror movie called get out that's all I
know thus far I know you saw a whole
interview record a live stream of I was
there man I shared the man's hand it's a
big deal so let's watch this see if his
sketch comedy skills come in handy
look now he's awesome rule and the King
no no no I don't you sure about that
looks so cool yeah oh I held up on this
trailer and man like I don't even know
what's going on but this is I'm looking
so forward to this like this is probably
the the film I'm most excited about now
coming up I love how Jordan Peele is
intentionally capitalizing off of the
whole black man in a horror movie oh you
want sensational couple and yeah yeah
normally in a horror movie I've nowadays
either black man dies versus black man
makes a call about a black guy it was
the first or something this time they're
really making that a thing like the fact
that it's black they're really making a
thing and they're toying with the fear
of racism and all that in a much more
extreme way it's like the ultimate
psychological horror film you got the
terrifying hypnosis aspect in there you
got just the interaction of a different
kind of society of people who probably
don't like black people you know the
perform was the main guy he's a factor I
don't know his name and that's what MD
buzz for a recognition Stanfield yeah I
recognize him from a from an episode of
Black Mirror I think he's on the second
episode and he's really great in that
like he's a he's really terrific I'm
happy to see him get a starring role in
this I know the female lead is from girl
yeah she's she's in girls she has a very
challenging role because I go back and
forth because yeah she's beautiful to
look at but at times I really don't like
her character but at the end of the day
her performance is still really good
she's a great actress and it's cool to
see her in a film like this Bradley
Woodford oh I didn't even recognize it
yes at first I heard his voice and then
I was like that voice sounds very
familiar then we got a little closer I
was like is that Bradley Whitford new
yeah they have a great cast here from
watching a lot of sketches from key and
Peele I bet this will be a horror comedy
like I don't well ah I bet there's I
know a humor I bet the trailer is much
more serious than the film itself I
don't think it's gonna be like flat-out
comedies what movie looks like it gets
pretty horrific Oh totally I take their
opt humor I think it I think there's
gonna be comedy and there's gonna be
terrifying [ __ ] as well though I don't
think it's gonna be a spoof of horrify I
feel like there's gonna be more horror
than
maybe yeah I wouldn't be surprised I
think in some ways it is a comedy I
think this is a good debate to have I
guess like instead of like hitting the
deer a deer gets thrown at their car you
know like he's not even driving but the
officers say like let me see your
license and stuff like there's I was I
was finding myself laughing the times
during this trailer I didn't think it
was gonna comedy notes that plays on a
lot of like you know relevant paranoia
and stuff like that you know relevant
things that might happen on a desert
country road perhaps but there's also
this strong level of Surrealism to it
yeah and I'm really enjoy like because
clearly the main character is seeing
that this is strange and weird even
there was kind of a denial of it at
first he is seeing it so seeing it
through the lens of his perspective I
bet there's gonna be like humor infuse
for sure you know it looks like it's
gonna get like you said surreal and and
strange and trippy and and things like
that cuz like this trailer is is nuts
like especially in the second half when
all that crazy stuff starts happening
like I don't know how all these things
figure in and what even some of them
yeah and I have no idea how this is
gonna play out yeah I can't tell you how
acting you know two and three you're
gonna go all I know is that like okay
yeah I'll give you some type of build up
whatever knowing from just seeing his
working with key and peele that Jordan
Peele will probably find will find ways
to make us think we know where this is
going but then flip it I've already felt
that in the trailer like with the guy
that one black dude running towards him
and he just immediately darts to the
right yeah you constantly think some
okay maybe this is what's gonna happen
but then it doesn't happen it's exciting
to see him making an actual film like he
wrote and directed this and you watched
key and Peele sketches and like you get
the sense that these guys love movie
they love know movies they incorporate
horror elements into their work often
they do and even there's like it's
sketch comedy but it's sketch comedy of
the newer variety that incorporates
humor that's based on the style and how
it's captured and how it's cut yeah I
mean I guess instead of saying comedy i
one thing i really love from this
trailer is that there's so much
personality today there's life to it you
know nowadays I see so many [ __ ]
horror trailers that are just like let's
try to be so serious yes scary and
there's a life here that adds the to the
fear at the same time yeah it's not just
okay sometimes it's fun sometimes it's
scary it's like a big blend of it all
this trailer just communicate
something very off is going to happen
and it's just gonna get more and more
off I'm really psyched that this gets to
be his sort of debut this way because
this at least like I don't want to see
anything after this trailer until the
movie comes out because I'm hooked right
here it looks like there's a lot of
striking strong stuff in this movie a
lot of great visual imagery too oh yeah
the hypnosis stuff looks like it's gonna
be [ __ ] awesome I'm glad that we're
getting a horror movie with what seems
like a legit you know black perspective
you know yes that's a cool thing by the
time we actually got one yeah yeah cuz
like you know especially with the shows
and stuff that are coming up more on TV
as a diversity sort of seeps its way and
like it's nice to see movies finally
catching up to that it seems like
cultural movies get relegated to only
those cultures like you know if you see
a movie with a predominantly black cast
it's only pitch to the you know the
black community and so this seems like
it's swinging why but it's still you
know very much has its own identity and
I'm happy about that especially now that
we've got more diverse TV shows and
stuff absolutely like Atlanta and the
get-down
you got all sorts of things coming along
like this I'm really psyched about for
that reason too it looks like a new
perspective to bring to this kind of
forum Jordan P oh man you're gonna be
much bigger than that show like that
shows already like really loved and
really regarded no it's over now with
the success of Keanu being critically
loved and the audience is really loving
it too and I know he co-wrote it's
co-starred in it this time it's like
he's not in front of the camera I think
he was aware that if he was in front of
the camera it might distract a little
bit yes for now I feel like just now it
would be that way maybe down the road he
could write and direct a movie that he
could also star a co-star in well you
know you never know if you might have a
kami on this yeah it would make more
sense for him to show up in a comedy
that he's writing directing than a
horror movie night I think that's weird
his [ __ ] to it I love that yeah weird it
looked and that was the cool thing I
mean like the the folks I work with they
had him on their on their podcast called
shockwaves it's a good interview and and
that's sort of what we learned today
Jews mad into horror and I always love
when people are allowed to in an
artistic environment like show their
other interests oh yeah oh yeah you do
comedy but but also you're really into
this other thing and here's what that
looks like when it comes from you you
know I really want to see Bradley
Whitford his work in this yeah it is he
I think Bradley Whitford is fantastic
with adding humor
and personality into a dramatic role and
this is exactly what I would want from
Bradley would four in a row oh yeah cuz
he's already creepy but likable already
in a trailer I'm like creepy and likable
at the same time Catherine Keener and
Bradley Whitford seem like a great
combination together to be her parents
because they both have a quality both
have a genuine sort of struck sick yeah
there's like a trust and a lot of
sincerity to them yeah
but they also they're also great actors
nobody knows yeah they're always
compelling a lot of roles for black
actors to in this movie to which is just
nice to see it seems like they're gonna
actually use horror as a method of
confronting some actual issues which you
know is part of the magic of genre films
like that's part of the the service that
genre movies sci-fi and horror can
provide is we can explore fears and
things like that through the allegory of
a creepy tale so I really hope it
delivers on all that stuff that was a
fantastic trailer can't wait to watch
that movie if every rarely faked can't
come any sooner
put it in my eyeball put it in my
eyeball put it in my mouth put it in my
behind if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects become
a rejected a do it Sean social media
manager of two things the Facebook sites
of real rejection bloom house and I want
to give a shout out to the very first
comment as several people requested this
but the first person who requested that
I saw a request this is Killam Dupree
Elam Dubrow perfect name for this video
kill him the pro I like Willem Dafoe not
bad I want to be surprised at Willem
Dafoe's ruling it was kill him the pro
he's one of the creepiest [ __ ]
I've ever seen kill him do pro if we
found out that Willem Dafoe was secretly
a serial killer and everyone was shocked
I'd be the only one like what well
shucks serial killer with like a rep see
him have you just seen him smile I would
love to be killed by Willem Dafoe if I
had to be I wouldn't he probably do
weird things to my body afterwards
sexual we long to follow though like it
what are you talking about he is no he's
disgusting this is Ryan Gosling killed
me I did let him do anything I do Shiloh
baring just Center
let him yeah you know